leading figures in Poland and the
European Union are in Gdansk today where
they are paying their respects to the
city's late mayor Pavel adamovich who
was fatally stabbed while on stage at a
charity event last Sunday the murder of
the liberal politician is believed to
have been politically motivated
adamovich is being remembered for his
civic engagement in his hometown and for
his willingness to speak up about his
convictions not even the cavernous st.
Mary's Church could provide enough space
for the mourners in Gdansk thousands
lined the streets to pay their respects
to Pavel adamovich their former mayor
and a man who embodied liberal values at
a time of political rancor in Poland
some wept as they watched the service on
specially erected big screens amid the
sorrow there was fear for the future
it's very sad that we've come here
together under these circumstances we
can't allow our society to be divided
the assassination last Sunday shows us
where that leads
[Music]
I'm here to take a stand against
aggression in our society and because I
want to honor the man who was our mayor
for 20 years our society is rife with
aggression nationalism and xenophobia I
see it every day
inside the church the polish Prime
Minister looked on as the Archbishop of
Gdansk echoed the calls for unity seeing
adamovich his death was a bell calling
for alarm
the presence of european council
president and ex polished Prime Minister
Donald Tusk himself a Gdansk native was
a reminder to of adamovich is continued
belief in the European Union but he was
a man of Gdansk a pole but also European
one who believed in European values
above all freedom and solidarity no
shoot Pavel adamovich was laid to rest
on Saturday in the city and whose
service he had spent his life many hoped
that his violent death allegedly at the
hands of a political opponent will prove
a catalyst in healing the country's
divisions joining us now live from
Gdansk is DW correspondent Monika
Zaretsky
Monika we understand you're outside the
church where the funeral is taking place
what have people there been telling you
well many of the people who came here to
dyn's
from all over Poland and from other
countries are still deeply shocked after
the tragedy with which happened six days
ago in Gdansk they don't really find an
answer any answer on question how is it
possible that it could happen in Poland
today in the heart of Europe and the
people are is have a memory of
adamovich who is very - today as a
person was open-minded tolerant and
wanted wanted to invite to the city of
Gdansk many different people from
different cultures also during the
funeral ceremonies today representatives
from different region religion religious
minorities living in Gdansk pray prayed
from prayed for him so the people here
will miss Cavell adamovich who was one
of the most important liberal voices
liberal progressive voices in Poland
today which is now under rule of the
National Conservative government I think
we can all understand why people are
looking for answers to the questions on
the ground there in Gdansk let me ask a
question to you though is it too early
at this point to talk about all this
having a wider European significance
I'm sure that it has a wider European
significance of many reasons not only
Poland is a country which is deeply
divided but also many other countries in
Europe are now divided and these
political divisions is are something
which for many politicians also in
Poland and in Europe in their opinion
can it be it can be dangerous it can
cause a lead to an atmosphere of hate
which can lead also to such criminal and
barbaric acts like this political murder
in Poland in Gdansk six days ago so
that's the reason also why different
politicians from other countries are
here today also the Polish high-ranking
politicians like Prime Minister and
president are attending but also Donald
Tusk who was a close friend to the
assassinated mayor who comes also from
Gdansk is now the president of the
European Council he is here and also the
former president of Germany are him many
and many mayors of German and other
cities in Europe this is a message going
here from Poland today from Dynes a
warning to many to the European people
and a call to end political divisions
and to have more tolerance and
understanding
okay thank you for that Monica Surratt
Scott in Gdansk